[Applaudissements]
vu des gosses chez nous du top niveau
qui nous font rêver
c'est aujourd'hui que ça se passe
officiellement lancement de saison pour
l'impact de montréal en mls et ça se
passe au stade olympique neuvième saison
donc pour le bleu blanc noir dans cette
ligue et pour en parler
on reçoit ce matin kevin gilmore
président de l'impact de montréal s'est
également bonjour au matin merci d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui très important
pour les pâtes avec l'engouement de la
semaine j'imagine que vous surfez sur
une des champions est arrivé là oui
c'est drôle ce début de saison
intéressant parce que c'est comme on
commence la saison dans les scieries
avant même de commencer la saison
mais ces cris beaucoup d'engouement
comme vous dites seront en plus du fait
que c'était notre premier match avec
thierry henry ici à montréal comme
nouvel entraîneur donc il ya beaucoup de
réseaux raison pour être exquis pour la
saison on vient de le voir à l'oeuvre un
thierry henry à montréal oui souvenez
vous je vous donne le choix vendre match
d'ouverture de mls 22 février à montréal
ou vendre un match de quart de finale de
ligue des champions de 10 mars au stade
olympique lequel est plus facile que je
pensais écoute moi je dirais que le fait
que la ligue des champions vient de
temps en temps c'est pas quelque chose
qui arrive à chaque année il ya beaucoup
plus de d'engouement dans marché pour
six matches là c'est qu'on les équipes
qu'on voit jamais on a une équipe du
honduras qui vient ici le dise donc
souvent ça crée beaucoup d'excitation
dans le marché c'est pour ça qu'on voit
avec chaque match comme on a vu en 2015
que les fall deviennent de plus en plus
imposante est importante il faut le
satisfaisante pour vous le 10 mars puis
aujourd'hui ce à quoi ça va ressembler
écouter aujourd'hui on s'attend à voir
une foule qui presque ex aequo avec ce
qu'on aurait salle comble au stade
saputo d'environ 20000 moi j'aimerais
voir trente mille personnes au stade le
dc pos plus parce que vraiment le corps
de financer devient de plus en plus
excitant et on voit que fait beaucoup de
travail aussi pour aller rejoindre les
fans mousser davantage le nombre de
partisans de l'impact on a vu la vidéo
tout à l'heure on en parlait à la table
des communications en créole en français
en anglais en italien
bagnols s'est voulu ça il ya des
marchands oui parce que oui parce que
vraiment j'ai toujours dit note l'ubs
représente la ville de montréal et même
le québec si on a onze joueurs sur le
terrain qui viennent de différents pays
différentes cultures différentes langues
puis sera 100 puis forment une
communauté sur le terrain puissent aussi
montréal montréal est une ville
multiculturelle très accueillante où
vraiment c'est un mix de toutes sortes
de différentes cultures etc
donc on veut parler à tout le monde
parce que vraiment le sort que ça parle
à tout le monde les jeunes argentins qui
est partie le nacho piatti bon sa
connexion avec le public elle était là
était le joueur le plus apprécié de
l'équipe évidemment avec raison
avez-vous ressenti une secousse
maintenant parce que vous le remplacez
le est-ce que qui va le remplacer ce que
vous vendez de l'espoir où ça s'en vient
mais je pense qu'une chose qu'on garde
en tête aux autres c'est que moi je dis
souvent on le fait avec nacho en fait
contre on préfère créer des étoiles que
amener des étoiles dans le sens que
nacho quand il n'existait pas un joueur
de qui était vraiment reconnue à travers
le monde comme un star et puis on le
établi ici
si c'est la beauté de joie comme nacho
qui choisit montréal choisi l'impact
choisi cette ligue pour vraiment devenir
un joueur un plus haut niveau
et puis on voit ça maintenant voix des
jeunes joueurs qui veulent venir
s'établir avec l'impact
on continue à rechercher des joueurs
pour vraiment s'améliorer mais j'ai
souvent que la construction d'un club ce
n'est pas quelque chose qui te fait d'un
jour à l'eau notre initiative on leur en
passe on remplacera pas de demain il
remet le kyoto qui mène avec les autres
joueurs offensifs et les joueurs comme
l'a si l'appareil n'est mort jack wanko
du point de vue offensif cependant je
pense qu'on est satisfait qu'on va être
capable de livrer la marchandise
enfin évidemment être justement
justement et puis vraiment la défensive
on a bouclé sa avec thierry avec ce
système tactique etc
je pense qu'on rentre dans la saison
avec beaucoup confort que malgré le
départ de natcho on va on va avoir une
équipe très excitante
il ya eu plusieurs blessés et ont par
contre on appris hier que le tout
nouveau capitaine devrait être absent
pour deux
à 3 mois jean-françois vous me disiez
tout à l'heure aussi le canard la liste
des blessés s'allonge à l'époque ça crée
des difficultés on a vu la même chose
donnée par si ça fait partie du sport il
ya des petites blessures et des grandes
blessures la blessure de wright à
l'assemblée sur de contact en fait
comptes qui dans ce cas ci est plus
allongée qu'on espérait mais ça donne la
chance à nos joueurs de rentrer dans
l'alignement et de prendre leur place
on a vu un event ce qui rentre et
l'autre jour mercredi et puis si tel ou
tel joueur du match
un jeune de 18 ans qui vient de
l'angleterre que encore une fois décidé
de venir à montréal
donc ça va donner une chance à des
jeunes joueurs de rentrer dans
l'alignement et s'établir comme un
joueur important de la ville avec des
ambitions modestes ou les ambitions
assez élevé non je dire on se donne des
ambitions modestes dont ce fait trois
ans qu'on n'a pas fait les séries donc
ça c'est notre but premier
on aussi des prêtres point de vue
collatéral le but d'avancer encore plus
loin dans la ligue des champions parce
que je pense que on a une chance avec
l'équipe du honduras de même se rendre
en demi finale si on joue notre jeu donc
oui on est en éruption modeste mais mais
modeste à court terme est très
ambitieuse à long terme stocker en
terminant on parle beaucoup de corona
virus on a vu en italie il ya des matchs
de soccer de foot qui ont été reportés à
plusieurs mois dans plusieurs mois
en france aussi on annuler des
événements vous de votre côté vous
suivez la serre on suit sur la ligue est
très très active dans dans la sud à la
suite du dossier pour s'assurer en fin
de compte qui est presque à chaque jour
on regarde la situation
présentement il ya aucune raison pour
pour faire de changements ici et nos
marchés nos nos matchs à l'étranger non
plus mais on regarde ce très très proche
mans avec la ligue bon match cet après
midi merci s'il vous plaît